[Music]
let me check my chest my breath right
quick
there's no denying charlie demilio is an
internet icon
very crazy in march charlie became the
most
followed person on tick-tock with over
50 million followers
so how did she get here before joining
tick tock in 2019
charlie danced competitively in her
hometown of norwalk connecticut
she started at just three years old she
practically
lived in the dance studio often
competing with her team throughout the
east coast
charlie was raised by her mom heidi a
photographer and fitness enthusiast
and her dad mark a businessman turned
politician
who ran for connecticut state senate in
2017.
according to his instabio he is now the
ceo of the demilio family
she has one sibling her older sister
dixie who is not far behind her on tick
tock with over 20 million followers
i'm a savage
in 2017 charlie began posting videos of
her hip-hop routines on instagram
[Music]
she started sharing more and more dances
eventually posting up to two to three
videos a week
cut to july 2019 she posted this
tick tock and went viral step step
flip flip shoulder shoulder hip hip
hands go up
hands go down move your booty all around
five months and lots of posts later
charlie had more than
five million followers on the platform
with hits like say so
let me check my chest my breath right
quick he ain't never
[Music]
[Music]
it's the dance that took tick-tock into
the mainstream with celebs like lizzo
a-rod and kourtney kardashian paying
attention
what does it mean when you hear from
stars like that you see them reposting
the stuff that you do
it doesn't seem real because i'm like
why why do they know who i'm just
dancing in
my room by myself why do they know who i
am
charlie also got the attention of the
hype house a group of popular creators
who all make content while living under
one roof
being only 15 charlie didn't officially
live in the home
but she was still considered a member of
the house and
the most popular creator in the group
speaking of popular
i'm ready you know you've made it when
you've got the attention of
jennifer lopez who invited charlie to do
the hashtag
jlo super bowl challenge on tick tock
[Music]
when i first met her and i got to shake
her hand and
i was just blank-faced i didn't know
what to say
and then it kind of set in and tears
just started rolling down my eyes
because this is all i ever really really
wanted to experience
charlie's star is rising but she's also
faced some controversy
in january people realize jalea harmon
was the original choreographer
of the renegade and although charlie
never claimed that she was the one who
created the viral dance
fans demanded that she publicly give
jalea the credit
and she did joining forces with jalea
for this
ultimate renegade moment
[Music]
she's also experienced what dating in
the spotlight is like
her romance with fellow tiktok creator
lil huddy caused
lots of conversation people say that
they everyone's different but
not that many people have her
personality in it and i think it really
stands out
the pair ultimately called things off in
april though with charlie posting this
emotional message on her instagram
asking her followers not to ask about
the breakup
so what's next for the teenage superstar
for now she's been traveling back and
forth between
la and connecticut with her family who
are all now
verified tick-tock stars in january
charlie and the entire demilio family
signed with the united talent agency to
develop various projects
including a possible reality show people
are always talking about
how they think our family dynamic is
pretty cool like they love it when we go
live
so that's super fun i mean it's really
whatever helps like
us showcase what we're really like these
days charlie's focus has also been
giving back
starting the hashtag distance dance
challenge on tick-tock
a fundraising campaign to serve
populations that have been impacted by
the covet 19 pandemic
on top of that charlie is making the
transition to hollywood
she voices a character in the new movie
star dog and turbo cat
there's so many opportunities that are
being presented to me right now i just
want to try
everything and see what works
you